hey Rich uh I've been listening for a
long time my first time calling in uh
it's pretty exciting cool um I'm a
28-year-old dude um I live in LA I have
a lot going for me I'm a third-year law
student here in La got some good career
prospects I've been in sales prior to
this so a pretty great people person I
just got out of a pretty long-term
relationship it was like six years long
and um you know contempt started
building up and that was ultimately the
end of the relationship and it was a a
huge hit to my ego so I'm little by
little trying to rebuild you know how I
feel about myself my Personal Image I do
all the things that you talk about right
I got my career in order I lost a lot of
weight I got shredded for the summer um
I do martial arts here and there I have
great friends all of them very educated
and successful yeah um one thing that I
feel like I'm struggling with is uh but
Sean but Sean did you watch the start of
the show do you wipe your butthole
properly yes I have a bedet very
important I I want so glad I'm on this
call every I just want to make sure we
got that out of the way because there's
a big demand for the gals on that Reddit
thread I I have skincare routine and my
hygiene is very on point not a boy sorry
carry on I didn't mean to interrupt you
no you're good thank you so actually
right now I'm gonna go see one of the
girls uh spinning you know one of the
plates that I'm spinning um but my
problem is that I feel like I should be
dating hotter chicks and I'm kind of
struggling to to do that maybe it's like
some of the colder approaching that I
struggle with but it's very hard to meet
people here in La is there anything that
you would recommend like
helps yeah yeah so rate the girls that
you're dating right now in a scale of 1
to 10 you know the plates that you're
spinning where they at between between
four and six four and six okay so rate
yourself on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being the best version of yourself where
do you fit so I give myself a solid
seven um I I think I have a lot going on
I think once I graduate pass the bar
exam get my career rolling um between
eight nine you you know I'm educated I'm
in great shape uh got a lot of things
going on I think how old are these gals
at you're
dating um so I'm 28 they're anywhere you
know under they're younger than me
sometimes they're older but the ones
that are older than me I don't take
seriously at all it's recreational use
only how much old are you
dating uh I think I think the one I'm
going to see right now is like
34 yeah 34y old cougar looking at the
28-year-old lost dud and eh you don't
you don't go younger than yourself of
course I do yeah I mean I i' i' hooked
up with a girl who was 20 and all the
way up to like 34 you know I'm actually
surp like you know when you describe
younger women they're generally not
fours right I mean if they're a four at
22 they're going to be like a minus four
at 35 right because you know women are
sort of like expiring by that point um I
know some people get so pissed off when
they say oh women don't expire you know
women Beauty Fates
yeah um so to deal with women that are
younger than you that are fours five
sixes I mean like why even bother why
you even going out with them like why
not do something else with your time
man so again I think it was like a huge
hit to my ego um I had a lot of future
planning around with my uh last
girlfriend yeah it was six years long so
it's just why you guys break up you said
something about contempt so what was the
so what was the contempt that led up to
the
breakup so I'm living at home because I
live 30 minutes uh from school and La is
a very high cost of living area and it's
you know it's I'm saving myself about
$20,000 in rent a year yeah and she she
was my age and she really wanted to get
our life going together and I think
because I kept pushing off you know
trying to get a place because I don't
want to pay gry star realy $3,000 a
month in rent where I'm looking to buy
something as soon as I graduate because
I'll have a six figure income did have
her own place or was she living with her
parents no she was living with me for a
little bit which was a little tough she
was living with you at your parents I
have a single mom so it's living with my
mom okay but still me like she was
living in your parents home though yes
that was also very difficult thing why
did you move her into your mom's
house it was early in the relationship
and um I was hesitant but my mom kept
inviting her in and just saying stay
with us because she was having some job
problems but by the end of the
relationship I mean my ex was making
like close to 130 but here here's the
thing I have a buddy who's uh just
graduated law school his girlfriend paid
for every single penny of their rent and
she made half as much as my ex so
looking back I'm like oh well my ex was
selfish
comparatively well I mean you moved her
into your house when she had a shitty PR
like you played Captain SEO or maybe
your mom did I don't know but like you
know move out and let's get a place
together what you were doing is
reasonable and honestly a lot of women
will look past that I mean you're going
to a chick's house right now yeah yeah
no problem right you still live at your
mom's house yep no problem you're GNA be
a lawyer in a few years making bucks
Deluxe right less than a year at this
point there you go right so it's like
you know she couldn't wait bye see you I
mean okay so back to your original
question CU I was just curious about why
you guys broke up so back to your
original question how do you get hot
women
yeah like money solves a lot of these
problems too man because especially in a
city like LA because they have the
expectation because there's this
glamorous [__] that's always on TV
with like real estate agents and the
Real Housewives and the real whatever of
Orange County and this County and the
other County so like the the
expectations of the hotter women is like
way in the clouds and you really need
Bank to um you know show up for that so
in a year's time when you're making a
lot more money things will change you
know dramatically as far as the options
that you you'll be able to have um
you're probably doing it right as far as
where you're at right now like you're
dating a few older cougars and spinning
them as plates not taking them seriously
fine good um I mean if you deal with a
younger woman that you know is fun and
sort of grows on you and like the cream
Rises to the top like spin the place
cream Rises to the Top If you want to
get into a relationship or monogamous
one or n monogamous you decide how it is
that you want to set it up but just keep
doing what you're doing I wouldn't sweat
it too much but I also disqualify women
that you're not attracted to right like
why would you want to go out with a four
like if you find a four five or a six
not that attractive then don't even
bother like don't even waste your time
and that'll preserve your energy um
you've read my
book that was a question have you read
my book no I haven't I started listening
to you all I'm in law school so Time
free time for uh extracurricular reading
is not possible for me right now get the
audio book actually wait the the second
edition of the Audi book will be
uploaded probably in the next week I was
talking to my editor today he's just
he's vidious about making it perfect but
get the book um I talk about it in a few
areas of the book but the reason why I'm
mentioning it is there's this energy
that sort of flows right um and energy
is like Distributing your [__] to
things that are truly fuckw worthy and
if you preserve it for yourself to use
that energy on your career maybe prior
PR izing it on any other any other area
of your own life that you can level up
then you won't waste your energy on
women that you're not even attracted to
because at the end of the day like why
do you even want to smash a four anyway
if you're not attracted to her like just
don't save your energy you know save
that Vitality in yourself for a gal that
you are hot for that's one of the other
things that I recommend as well too but
I talk specifically in one of the
chapters about managing your [__] is
you know the way that I place it it
applies to almost any area in your life
if you want to unplug it just from that
generalization you can use it in
business transactions you can use it
dealing with women all kinds of
different areas just contemplate that
okay yeah it's actually not that complex
man just just don't deal with subst
substandard women and if all you're
getting is substandard women there's
something within you that you're missing
somewhere like there's some area you're
not I mean you said you're good-looking
you're together like you're fit you said
yeah height and
weight I'm 5 foot eight um at the bottom
of my cut I was like 163 sixpack
benching like broad shoulders narrow
waist yeah like classic physique build
okay not on gear or anything um and now
I'm like 170 I'm bulking out again so I
filled out filling out again yeah some
guys will like [__] on you and say oh
well you're not tall enough because
you're not over six foot that's [__]
as long as she's shorter than you and
she can look up at you it's totally fine
um no i' I've dated girls taller than me
I mean I height has never been a my
problem I mean I I've hooked up with
women been taller than me yeah never
good yeah so I just want to make sure
that's not something that's holding you
back good all right good you're good to
go man just again you know spend the
time on yourself and don't don't waste
it on the lower value women and the
areas in your life that you can't
improve it it just sounds like money
social network being more captivating
you know like all of those things you
can work on as you sort of climb out of
school and sort of move into the real
world and get that job that's going to
pay you big bucks I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out